Before he ever picked up a lightsaber, Eman
Esfandi was firing away precision strikes
with a very different implement.
From showing up in random commercials to throwing
down at slam poetry shows, here's what you
didn't know about the "Ahsoka" star.
Eman Esfandi grew up in the small Texas border
city of Laredo, which is known for having
the highest proportion of Hispanic Americans
of any city in the United States outside of Puerto Rico.
This lack of ethnic diversity proved challenging
for Esfandi, whose mother hails from Ecuador
and whose father comes from Iran.
As he explained to The Daily Texan in 2022,
"I was around zero Persian people my whole
life, mostly around Mexican and Caucasian people.
Texas Caucasian people can be really rough,
especially the years I was growing up.
Very country, homophobic, Islamophobic, [and]
brutal."
And in an interview with Flaunt, Esfandi recalled,
"[I] grew up with the repercussions of 9/11
all throughout my childhood.
When I was younger it wasn't as noticeable,
but by the time I was in high school, I could
better see the microaggressions that my being
half-Persian, or my father being from Iran, would incite."
Esfandi would later utilize this racism to
help fuel his career.
Esfandi's parents have been business owners
in Laredo for most of their son's life.
He spent a considerable amount of his childhood
in the family shop and even hoped to one day
follow in their footsteps.
So he got an associate's degree from his hometown
school of Laredo College, and then he later
graduated from the University of Texas with
a Bachelor's in Economics with the expectation
of running a business similar to his parents'
shop.
But then he changed his focus when he discovered
a passion for film and art.
As he recalled to Shoutout LA in 2021,
"I wasn't taught how to express myself, didn't
have any examples of how to become an artist.
I'm grateful though, for it's the stark contrast
of my upbringing to my current lifestyle.
It's humbling and empowering to remind myself
that I started from nothing and wasn't handed
things on a silver platter."
There was yet another completely different
life trajectory that Esfandi almost ended
up on, as he was once considered to be a bit
of a tennis prodigy.
He took up the sport at the age of 13 and
spent his high school senior year practicing
at the John Newcombe Tennis Academy in New
Braunfels, Texas.
He was even at one point ranked in the top
five in the country while playing collegiate
tennis at Laredo College.
Esfandi kept playing for years, and he eventually
became a mentor and an instructor for tennis
prospects of all ages as recently as 2020.
His athletic background came in handy in 2021
when he landed a small role in the movie King
Richard, which tells the story of Richard
Williams, father of the legendary Venus and Serena.
"This guy, Richard Williams, keeps calling.
It's like the tenth time in a row."
Esfandi remains obsessed with the game, as
he regularly shares highlights of his practices
and matches on Instagram.
With a sports background and a fine education,
it wasn't exactly the obvious choice for Eman
Esfandi to dive headfirst into acting.
But he found his own direction in life by
taking a unique route.
As he explained to Voyage LA in 2019,
"I had been conducting impromptu 'interviews'
at coffee shops around Austin with anyone
who was interested in starting up a conversation
[...] It was my way to research different
life paths without having to experience them
myself."
Esfandi eventually took his project to a local
acting workshop.
As he recalled,
"I did, in fact, meet people who had drastically
changed their life paths, but another interesting
thing also happened.
I ended up volunteering to work through a
couple of scenes."
Esfandi impressed the casting directors who
were operating the workshop and was encouraged
to find a manager and pursue an acting career.
So he started attending workshops around Austin
and landed some substantial roles in student
projects and short films before fully committing
by making the move to Los Angeles in 2018.
Like plenty of other actors, Eman Esfandi
got his start on screen with some TV commercial gigs.
Impressively enough, he landed his first nationally
televised campaign shortly after attending
his first acting workshop.
Since then, Esfandi has managed to book a
veritable slew of ads, for the likes of such
companies as Amazon, Bose, and H&R Block.
One spot for L.L.
Bean features him sleeping on top of a ladder
of hammocks as he wishes his camping mates
a good morning.
He also appeared in Coca-Cola's "Food Feud"
campaign, which features people making their
cases for various meals as the optimal thing
to eat while watching football.
Esfandi plays a guy who stumps for a certain
type of iconic sandwich.
"Dude, subs."
For many actors, it's a natural evolution
to one day sit in the director's chair and
run the show behind the camera.
Eman Esfandi has actually already made this
transition, as he's an award-winning director
of short films.
His first and most notable stint as a director
came as a passion project alongside his childhood
friend, Isaac Garza.
Garza approached Esfandi about helping him
produce an absurdist comedy short titled Pepito.
With Garza writing and starring, he invited
Esfandi to be the director.
So Esfandi taught himself how to direct by
devouring a crash course of YouTube videos,
and then he took the helm for the three-day
shoot.
To their surprise, Pepito went on to be selected
as a winner of the Latinx Short Film Festival
in 2019, and it also earned a nationwide distribution
deal on HBO platforms.
Esfandi followed up that triumph by directing
another short film called 120, which premiered
at the Cannes Short Film Corner.
Since then, though, he's pretty much abandoned
the director's chair, as he's chosen instead
to focus on his acting and other creative
pursuits.
The COVID-19 pandemic left a huge percentage
of the world's population to their own devices
while they were locked up in quarantine.
Eman Esfandi decided to use this isolation
to his advantage by pursuing artistic outlets
beyond filmmaking.
This included discovering a love for slam
poetry.
Slam poetry involves performing an original
piece in front of an audience that's encouraged
to participate with finger snaps or words
of affirmation.
This eccentric genre of live entertainment
is fitting for someone like Esfandi, as it's
often treated as a highly emotional monologue
that relies on the performer's individual style.
He's continued to practice this unique art
form, including in March 2023 when he shared
an Instagram reel of himself performing a
rendition of his poem "I'm Tired.”
"You good?
Hey you good?"
It was a natural progression for Esfandi to
adapt his passions for poetry and performing
into a music career.
Under the stage name of DragonWulf, he spent
much of his time in quarantine learning everything
he could about producing his own songs.
As he explained to the Laredo Morning Times
in 2023,
"I learned so much about music over the course
of a year [...] I realized I want to do this
all the way and forever."
Esmandi released his first DragonWulf EP in
September 2020, though he eventually decided
to make it no longer available.
As he explained,
"I took a more professional approach to learning
it all [...] while carving out my style and
figuring out what it is I wanted to do with
the music."
Esfandi then released a new single, "You're
Perfect in Every Way," and he's since followed
that up with three albums, A DragonWulf Summer,
La Vie En Vert, and La Sagrada Familia.
Esfandi has looked back on his musical journey
by reflecting,
"It was a lot of self and inner work and discovery
and expression.
It broke through a bunch of barriers of fear,
anxiety, and insecurity and eradicated all that."
Working on something as big as Ahsoka is sure
to help Esfandi land himself some higher profile
projects in the near future.
But he's actually already built himself a
pretty solid filmography.
His onscreen credits date back to 2017, when
he starred in an assortment of short films
with names like Death by Script and Mother
of the Golds.
By 2018, Esfandi hooked up with fellow Star
Wars veteran Robert Rodriguez.
The actor starred in Rodriguez's low-budget
flick Red 11, which had its world premiere
at the 2019 SXSW Film Festival.
Esfandi then made his silver screen debut
in 2021's King Richard before taking a more
substantial role in 2022's The Inspection.
It was a part that really hit close to home,
as he played a Muslim-American man recruited
into the Marines during the height of post-9/11
Islamophobia.
"Have you ever been convicted of a felony?
Are you communist?"
As impressive as Esfandi's rise through the
Hollywood ranks has been, he's still faced
some adversity, particularly when it comes
to the type of roles he gets offers for.
Since moving to Los Angeles in 2018, he's
gone out on plenty of auditions.
Unfortunately, the parts that he generally
gets the most calls for are stereotypical,
and frequently racist, characters that seem
to be stuck on his Iranian heritage.
As he noted to The Daily Texan in 2022,
"I'm not going to audition for something that's
offensive.
I'm not perfect for [a role] because I'm brown.
I'm not perfect for that because I can play
this side character.
I'm perfect for real characters because I'm
a real person."
Esfandi also pointed out that his role in
The Inspection was a good example of the sort
of character he prefers to play.
In that film, he was able to represent both
his Persian background and his Ecuadorian heritage.
Meanwhile, the part also allowed him to explore
and confront much of the racism that he's
endured throughout his life.
It's difficult for Esfandi to ignore how meteorically
his career has taken off by playing a fan-favorite
character in one of the world's biggest franchises.
But that doesn't mean that this development
is a total surprise to him.
He credits the power of manifestation as a
major reason for his success.
It's also a huge influence on his music, as
the power of belief has helped him turn his
dreams into reality.
As he explained to The Laredo Morning Times,
"I'm rapping from a place in the future that
I'm adopting the feeling of and calling that
into my life [...] I dropped A DragonWulf
Summer, and it's very flex rap and extravagant.
I'm flexing.
And that's when I booked Star Wars.
It doesn't get more obvious that these concepts
work."
Esfandi also noted,
"I know how the universe works on a spiritual
level, and I know I can get a hold of it on
a physical, tangible level [...] If anything,
at the end of this whole thing, I'll be living
proof and these songs will be my retrospect."
It's no secret that the Star Wars fandom can
be quite finicky when new characters, or new
versions of established characters, enter
the franchise.
All you have to do is go anywhere on the Internet
where Star Wars fans gather to understand
how difficult they can be to please.
But plenty of viewers seem to be embracing
Esfandi as the live-action choice for beloved
Rebels hero Ezra Bridger.
So it might be a little surprising to learn
that Esfandi had some serious competition
during the casting process.
Many actors expressed interest in the role
for Ahsoka, and one of the leading names rumored
for the part was the lead of the live-action
Aladdin, Mena Massoud.
Massoud even quoted Ezra on an Instagram post
back in 2021, which fueled speculation that
he was close to nabbing the part.
Massoud inevitably had to address the casting
decision when it was announced that Esfandi
won the part.
In a since-deleted tweet, he wrote,
"Glad the rumors will stop now.
Never really had a fair shot at it, unfortunately
[...] just wasn't meant for me, I guess.
Can't deny the dude looks exactly like Ezra."
It all seems to have worked out for the best,
as Esfandi is flourishing in the role, leading
to rumors that Ezra Bridger may get his very
own Disney+ series in the near future.